Hello Freak bitches.
I,
I've used it a sign.
I found myself,
his him from time to time,
just for the fuck of it and hangs it.
Feel good.
Hangover,
hangover.
You feel like a vampire vampire is looked like right?
They look at,
they're hung over like when the sun comes out of
fucking,
what a weird idea is that sometimes you can have vampires that fall all the
vampire rules until real recently people got so fucking arrogant.
They were like,
well,
no,
no.
Now Vampires are actually your friend and they only eat deer and they don't burn
when it's sunny out.
They just glisten and they don't want to be glistening.
They sparkle Joe.
They don't listen.
They sparkle just vampires all of a sudden became cool and you could fuck them.
Oh yeah dude.
Well that's Andrew Rice's fault.
Right?
And rise or phone.
Oh my God.
The fucking interview with a vampire.
No,
I don't think so man.
Because even before interview with the Vampire,
Dracula was very sexual.
Dracula was a hypnotic.
Yeah,
he was a very sexual and like a lot of the older movies,
you know,
there was a few of them.
The Gary Oldman.
What came first?
Gary Oldman or Anne Rice?
Probably in rice.
Right.
I don't want to Gary Oldman Dracula.
I think Anne Rice,
I'm always positive.
Actually.
I don't know the fucking Old Dracula,
I think the,
the Brahm Stoker Dracula.
Oh,
that was a long traps and the castle didn't he have like there was a room you
went into and there are all these female vampires.
Runyon hot.
Is that a call?
Yeah,
and like they were seductive and they would like,
you know,
they were powerful Dracula.
That's the good point of what everyone's hating on Dracula.
It's got these hard pitches that want to suck blood.
They're ready to throw it out.
That's so funny.
Just gets a bone him.
He never bound them in front of you buddy though.
It was just,
I guess once you start drinking people's blood that's like way cooler than
bowling and checks.
He just completely give up on bowling.
I mean in the world of vampires,
it's that is boning the best track live though of all time?
Unquestionably.
It was Gary Oldman.
Did you see that one?
I don't.
Bram stoker I sold.
It's so good that Kiana Reeves can't fuck it up.
I got it like I don't know cause I haven't seen it,
but I'll tell you my favorite fucking vampire or the way I do like Keanu Reeves.
It's just as cheap joke.
I like calories.
It's true.
I love you can't,
Oh God,
I love you didn't pay attention to my joke.
You just waiting to see what you going to say.
I'll tell you why.
Here's where my mind started wandering is you said the greatest vampire and then
I thought,
no,
no.
The greatest vampire of all time.
The spookiest vampire about time.
It's fucking Nosferatu.
Oh,
the original.
Yeah,
you're right.
Fuck that thing.
We'll also,
that was like really original.
I mean,
and think about that guy did that.
It was like,
what else is a silent movie now?
Man,
that thing was a scary son of a bitch,
whatever.
That was like,
that's what a vampires like the long fingers kind of Goblin fucking creepy thing
pops out of the shadows.
That onsite dude,
keep talking.
I love it.
Sorry my,
my yapping too much.
Oh,
I love it.
you do?
Really?
Yeah,
man.
Last fed out to.
Yeah,
man,
that guy is fucking scary.
But you know,
the Salem's lot vampires are pretty fucking spooky to 1922 brother,
1922 and I'm looking at the images of it right now.
Oh my God.
It's fucking incredible.
Yeah.
It was legitimately frightening.
Legitimately frightening.
And it was in the fucking early 19 hundreds dude.
Rentable.
And they find fucking coffin still too.
You know,
they found coffins out there are people have hammered stakes into the Oh yeah.
Well there's probably,
I'm sure people that were fucking assholes and they just wanted to make sure
that it really never came back.
But this motherfucker was creepy.
You're right,
man.
You know,
he might be the scariest whenever.
Yeah.
Especially when you consider it was 90 fucking years ago.
Man,
that was fucking spit.
Well,
I mean now it's based on the real thing.
Whatever is wandering around out in the fucking woods of Germany.
That's what was out there.
What a crazy people.
Do you remember?
Uh,
it was,
uh,
it was based on a real man.
The,
Oh my God,
look,
there's fucking photo of it,
dude.
It's a really good goddamn image.
I didn't really fucking scary looking.
Yeah,
that's a scary vampire.
1922,
because if you go watch like King Kong,
King Kong is not really scary.
And that's a little from like the 30s.
Nope.
Not Scary at all.
And it's scary.
It can con can not fuck with Nosferatu.
No,
not,
I mean,
I guess if I had to pick who I wanted to run from,
it's going to be a fucking Nosferatu though.
But I weird.
Is it that they just hijacked the whole vampire thing?
Vampires used to be the worst shit that could ever happen to and now he's a
hunky guy.
Well,
I'll tell you why they fucking did that shit,
bro in it.
Yeah.
You got to sell it to teenagers.
It's women,
men,
lot of women.
Well,
people that want the want romance,
right?
The,
uh,
the thing about the twilight books,
so I've been told by Mrs Rogan,
uh,
is that the very romantic,
unrealistically romantic because he's a vampire and it's like he's got all the
super power and everything like that.
It's like he,
like he's giving it all up,
but just to be with her,
you know what I mean?
And it's this weird sort of like,
he,
he needs her so much and women love that shit.
It's just a natural sort of a thing for though.
So like when you see women that would be waiting in line to go to those movies,
that just,
it just hits a chord that we don't,
we don't have,
we don't know that court,
but the Chica wrote that shit knows their cord.
So she nailed it.
She talking about the quarter love,
I'm talking about the court of affection and admiration.
Like I think all women want to be,
you know,
the w don't want to be worshiped,
they think that that's like the most romantic thing for a guy who would do
anything for you.
So he would do anything for that girl in,
in,
in those books.
He would do anything for,
I mean he,
he didn't even want to bite her.
He wanted to,
he wanted to protect her from everybody who was in love with her.
Meanwhile,
he was like a thousand years old and she's in high school.
Like it's really fucking creepy if you stop and think about it.
He's a thousand years old or whatever the fuck it is.
I tell them she's in high school,
man,
you are.
You're fucking crazy kind of conversations you're having with her.
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
it'd be hard enough if you were 30 you were 30 and you're dating a girl in high
school,
you'd be like,
I got to kill myself.
I can't take it.
I can't talk to her.
She's fucking just shows.
All she wants to talk about is Instagram thousand year old per se.
Fucking creeper ups.
He's a total creeper.
She could be as great Greg.
It's not like he just was frozen for all those years.
Like captain America.
No,
this asshole's been alive the whole time and pretend that he's in high school.
It might be one of the dumbest ideas ever.
It's not fair.
He's got magical powers.
He can fly.
He's flying a fucking high school kid through the trees.
Jesus Christ.
Did they fuck?
Yes.
Eventually.
Yeah.
Later in the boiler spoiler.
Yes.
Allegedly.
How about that?
I Dunno.
It was.
It already happened.
It might have already happened.
I only saw like two of them.
I think there's been three of them.
Put it in her asshole.
I don't think they had partial lot to do that.
It's a sin even for vampires.
Vampires.
No,
no,
no.
Females.
That project,
we'll cut the shape.
Just stop it.
They don't even shit anymore,
so it probably drives up nice,
don't shit.
When you're eating blood,
they probably barely have to urinate.
You probably get the exact amount you need.
You don't know that.
I would imagine you would get the exact amount you need now,
man of vampires.
Asshole is swollen.
Brogan.
A scene where you walked down into a New York City subway and you saw some crazy
looking vampire dude.
You shitting blood,
which is blood squirting out of his chunky cottage cheese blood.
That's what a vampire looks like.
Tunnel,
subway tunnel,
just shitting blood,
looking at you and thinking about sucking your blood next.
It's weird like that's that.
That's as far as they go.
Like vampires suck your blood.
That's the worst thing they do,
but there's never been like a supernatural creature that won't be like mouth
fucks you.
You know what I mean?
Some,
we talked about that before.
As ridiculous as it is.
I think we actually did talk about this before.
It must be on my fucking mind,
man.
There's no fucking bat or some creepy for rapes people.
There was mouth rape and dudes,
I don't use that word,
but it they're a fucking arm.
Horrifying,
horrifying being.
It doesn't have to be a vampire.
He could just be some bug,
some insect or something that came out of the earth and that's how it does it.
It just fucking,
it made her,
it leaves off of the,
it lives off of like people gagging.
It absorbs the
gagging.
It gets power for the trick.
The twitching of your body when you're trying to throw up gag pyre pipe is
clogged by fat cock.
You can't even throw up.
You're trying to throw up and he's just holding the back of your head with Scaly
Paul.
That's what they came to do.
They just came to get head.
They have a really tough dicks.
Like you really cannot even pierce the skin.
You can bite it as hard as you want.
It doesn't matter when alien's face fuck you.
They just did.
It just goes in.
You accept it and it,
it just fucks your throat when you try to throw up.
But he can't get past the fat alien cock that's stretching your insides out,
pumping oxygen.
And by the way,
it's keeping you alive in you alive.
Why you suck at Scott's.
It changes your whole,
it blows your lungs out and actually eats them and uh,
converts it to a type of glue that keeps the cock attached to your body to keep
you alive.
Cause now you no longer have lungs.
You get all your oxygen through his cock.
Oh my God.
Could you imagine?
That would be the word.
And in some people would say,
you know what,
I don't care.
I love aliens anyway.
There's still awesome her teaching us.
Listen,
if for him might be really awesome,
maybe he loves the fact that he's getting the oxygen to that cock.
You stay alive.
Your body where there's a way you can't really move.
Your arms are flailing and you like him paled,
you just look like a skeleton with a fucking Dildo in its mouth and every year
it just goes deeper in your body,
keeps that keeps growing.
Eventually it turns into you,
you just turn it in like a cactus like cactus Dick thing.
If you look at Sugar Bob Shish Kebab,
Dick Kebab every year the the,
the,
the Dick slowly grows inside your body and starts cracking open.
Oregon's and pushing ribs to this side,
popping and snapping them as it eventually goes through your body.
But it does it so slowly that you never actually die,
especially since the,
uh,
the deck is providing with oxygen,
but then when it gets to the hat,
to the end,
the deck pops out of your asshole and you deflate like a balloon.
And that,
and that sound is that sound is known as funking.
Like it's like the sound of a man's final farm.
There's no words sound.
It's like a pinky.
Okay.